we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's
something that I get a lot okay and this
is a caller who seems to have built up
an entire false reality in their mind
take a listen to this
hey David my name is Michael I've been
calling in to you and Sam cedar and as
well as Michael Brooks for a little bit
I feel like you're all kind of a little
bit nervous to debate me because I'm a
conservative you know I have differing
viewpoints maybe I'm a little bit more
convincing enough you're put to a debate
open to you know open exchange of ideas
and the marketplace of ideas you know
feel free to I you know give me a call
back what is this person talking about
right I mean it sadly this type of thing
is more common than you might think I
regularly get calls from people who
believe that there is a whole sort of
thing going on that I I mean what I have
no clue who this person is so what what
do they mean that he gets the sense that
I'm very nervous to debate him because
he's a conservative I mean it's just III
don't I genuinely don't know where to
feel bad and I don't want to make fun of
this person because some people do call
into the show who actually are mentally
ill and they're very disconnected from
reality and and that's you know that's
sad and I don't want to be making fun of
that but we've had people who believe
I'm sort of discreetly sending the
messages through the show subliminally
that there's a subtext to what's going
on then I'm addressing the show to them
specifically that I'm calculating what
to say in order not to upset them or to
upset them in some cases it's actually
sad I don't know who this person is I
don't know what they're talking about
that I and and other hosts are nervous
about debating them if you want to
challenge me about something we take
live calls every week they aren't
screened any conservative can get on any
time they want and challenge me about
whatever they want I'm not nervous and I
welcome back but I think that there's a
sort of Fantasyland element to what's
going on here and whether it's quirky or
funny or sad or disturbing or concerning
I don't really know but I don't know who
you are and I'm not nervous about
debating you and I encourage you to call
in absolutely any time we've got a great
bonus show for you today things are not
going well in the dominican republic as
a tenth american has died we're going to
talk about that as well as would a
to be a bogus study related to
smartphones and the idea of sending
astronauts back to the moon by 2024 just
four years away is that possible is it
feasible all of those stories and more
on the bonus show today
sign up at WWE a common com